two million five hundred and eighty
thousand seven hundred and sixty nine
tests for coronavirus have now been
carried out in the UK including ninety
one thousand two hundred six tests
carried out yesterday two hundred forty
three thousand three hundred and three
people have tested positive thus an
increase of three thousand one hundred
and forty two cases since yesterday
unfortunately due to technical issues
Northern Ireland have been unable to
process any testing data for pillar one
today today's daily totals therefore
reflect pillar one data for Great
Britain only excluding Northern Ireland
Northern Ireland are looking to resolve
this issue as soon as possible
and will update the data when we can ten
thousand and thirty five people are in
hospital with cope nineteen down 15
percent from eleven thousand eight
hundred and seventeen this time last
week and sadly of those tested positive
uh coronavirus across all settings
thirty four thousand six hundred and
thirty six have now died that's an
increase of one hundred and seventy
fatalities since yesterday
our thoughts are very much with the
families and loved ones of those who've
lost their lives
before talking about the work on
vaccines and taking questions I just
want to remind everyone of the details
of the next phase of our fight against
coronavirus could I have slide wand Ares
so first in order to monitor our
progress we have established a Nuke Ovid
alert level system with five levels each
relating to the level of threat posed by
the virus the alert level is based
primarily on the r-value and the number
of coronavirus cases and in turn that
alert level will determine the level of
social distancing measures in place the
lower the level the fewer the measures
the higher the level the stricter the
measures throughout the period of
lockdown which started on master 23rd we
have been
level-4 thanks to you people across the
country we have collectively helped to
bring the our level down and we are now
in a position to begin moving to level
three in careful steps slight to please
we have set out the first of three steps
we will take to carefully modify the
measures gradually ease the lockdown and
begin to allow people to return to their
way of life but crucially was avoiding
or will be a disastrous second peak that
overwhelms the NHS after each step we
will closely monitor the impact of that
step on the are and the number of
infections and all the available data
and we will only take the next step when
we are satisfied that it is safe to do
so as the Prime Minister announced this
week as part of the first step those who
cannot work from home should now speech
their employer about going back to work
you can now spend time outdoors and
exercise often as you like you can meet
one person outside of your household in
an outdoor public place provided you
stay two metres apart slide three please
having taken the first step in carefully
adjusting some of the measures and our
advice to people on what to do
we have also updated what we are asking
people to do which is to stay alert
control the virus and save lives staying
alert for the vast majority of people
still means staying at home as much as
possible but there are a range of other
actions for advising people to take
people should stay alert by working from
home if you can limiting contact with
other people keeping distance if you go
out to metres apart where possible
washing your hands regularly wearing a
face covering when you are in enclosed
spaces where it's difficult to be
socially distant for example in some
shops and on public transport and if you
anyone in your household has symptoms
you all need to self isolate because if
everyone stays alert and follows the
rules
we can control coronavirus by keeping
the are down and reducing the number of
infections this is how we can continue
to save lives as we begin as a nation to
recover from coronavirus but in order to
definitively conquer this disease we
need to find a safe workable vaccine
last month I announced a new vaccine
task force to coordinate the efforts of
government academia and industry in the
critical mission to find a vaccine I'm
very proud of how quickly our scientists
and researchers have come together in
their efforts develop a vaccine that
will combat coronavirus their work has
meant that two of the world's
frontrunners to develop a vaccine are
right here in the UK at the University
of Oxford and Imperial College London
the first clinical trial of the Oxford
vaccine is progressing well with all
phase one participants having received
their vaccine dose on schedule earlier
this week they're now being monitored
closely by the clinical trial team the
speed at which Oxford University has
designed and organized these complex
trials is genuinely unprecedented
Imperial College are also making good
progress and we will be looking to move
into clinical trials by mid-june with
larger scale trials planned to begin in
October so far the government has
invested 47 million pounds in the Oxford
and imperial vaccine programs but today
I can announce an additional 84 million
pounds of new government funding to help
accelerate their work this new money
will help mass produce your flu vaccine
so that if current trials are successful
we have dosages to start fascinating the
UK population straight away the funding
will also allow Imperial to launch phase
3 clinical trials for this vaccine later
this year I can also confirm that with
government support Oxford University has
finalised a global licensing agreement
with Astra
Seneca for the commercialization and
manufacturing of the Oxford vaccine this
means that if the vaccine is successful
AstraZeneca
will work to make 30 million doses
available by September for the UK as
part of an agreement at over 100 million
doses in total the UK will be first to
get access or we can also ensure that in
addition to supporting people here in
the UK were able to make the vaccine
available to developing countries at the
lowest possible cost to further support
our domestic manufacturing capability
last month I announced oh the government
will accelerate building the UK's first
vaccines manufacturing innovation center
which is based at Harwell in oxygen and
today I can announce that we will invest
up to a further 93 million pounds in the
centre ensuring that it opens in summer
2021 a full 12 months ahead of schedule
the center which is already under
construction will have capacity to
produce enough vaccine doses to serve
the entire UK population in as little as
six months but if and it is a big if a
successful vaccine is available later
this year we will need to be in a
position to manufacture it at scale and
quickly so whilst center is being built
the government will establish a rapid
deployment facility thanks to a further
investment of 38 million pounds to begin
coronavirus vaccine manufacturing at
scale from this summer this facility
will support efforts to ensure a vaccine
is widely available for the UK public as
soon as possible
in total the government has now
committed over a quarter of a billion
pounds towards developing a vaccine in
the UK but there are no certainties in
spite of the tireless efforts of our
scientists it is possible that we may
never find a successful coronavirus
vaccine so we also need to look at other
drug treatments and therapeutics for the
who get the virus treatments that could
prevent people progressing to sit there
severe illness or help save lives of
those with serious symptoms whilst there
are currently no drugs in the world that
have been clinically proven to treat
coronavirus the government is working
with our scientists and medical experts
to identify promising candidates this
collaborative UK program known as Accord
aims to get an early indication of drug
treatment effectiveness in treating
coronavirus and today I can report that
six drugs have now entered initial live
clinical trials if positive results are
seen they will advance into larger scale
trials our scientists are working
tirelessly to develop vaccines and drug
treatments condensing work that would
usually take years into months and even
weeks their drive and dedication
inspires us all and with their help we
will overcome coronavirus